foreign
[Music]
hey
hello I'm currently waiting outside the
clinic I'm not allowed to come in
unfortunately because of kovid Micah is
doing her Eco I think now we can
actually find out the gender so you kind
of hope for both in a weird way like
I'll be happy either way but I can't
wait to find out like I want to know she
said I'm paying now so she's coming out
soon what a mom
we got all the veggies prep look at
these
program
you know I had like five star Sushi
yesterday
that was better that holds up you know I
love these things they look freaky but
they're like the clump of mushrooms
so I'm almost a sweet dog and all but
for some some reason she hates
oh my God
Mama now
she hates taking off the leash and she
gets really mad how are we supposed
laughs
[Laughter]
what are you doing you're psycho
[Music]
are you sleeping in my headphones what
are we listening to here some relaxing
Abba
well do you guys want to see the most
useless 3D print of all time
I don't want to break it
when we leave we like to put a camera
for eggy so we can spy on him but cable
too long
thumb so I printed this
goes on the bank
Clicks in nice now we have this part
there we go so [__] dough I can wrap
it around
cable ties get the [__] out there we go
that's right tidy cables
my last day
around her now oh not anymore sorry
[Music]
it's snowing
so we got your footsies Mama how you
like them
[Music]
she doesn't hate them
she looks like a kangaroo more every day
oh thank you I'm almost getting used to
then
this is the first time I see snow in
Japan or Japan and snow rather so pretty
you're doing it Mama
I love the sound it makes
you know it would never snow in Brighton
it was very rare I don't think it ever
covered even like this we lived there
for eight years as a suite I'm
moderately excited about snow but this
is really nice I love it
what is he doing Peggy you look so good
okay
Edgar
why
[Music]
you okay there how are you so cold I'm
sorry
oh you had so much snow on you again you
look so cute
foreign
[Music]
I'll take this one okay
whoa no more
[Music]
we're going to Arizona 400 Valentine's
Day we've been there many years ago
lucky with the weather again so nice
every time we travel that's right lately
[Music]
look at it on
it in the middle he's here
you gotta see it you saw it
there's a tiny Venus
it's about the size of anchors
[Music]
out
there's no heat
how does it work hey don't go there
welcome
it's nice it's cozy there's no railing
upstairs so hopefully
mama will have a parachute as well
we got this now
[Music]
what's going on Gamers we're in a lake
it's awesome there's supposed to be
eliminations Mama wanted illuminations
This is BS I'm cold
I reject my swedishness
I look like a riddler in this
[Laughter]
what's long and hard and has come in the
middle cucumber
so cute
[Music]
I have to go up Momo
I'm almost scared of the slipper
[Laughter]
well he's so scared of a sleeper
[Music]
thank you
we're the ski slot it's minus six
degrees but it's nice how's it going
nice guys oh thank you you too
what did they just say to me uh I guess
they understood I was vlogging hey
we're going to the jet tubing
it's a non-actual skiing it looks fun we
got bad news I guess it's more intense
than we thought it was
sorry Marcia you make a snowman
[Music]
that was so scary
I'm glad you didn't go on that you would
have died
it's so cute hello
[Music]
so this is more like a snow park but you
can still ski and snowboard but it's not
really like a resort or whatever it's
called but it's cool I like it and the
weather is nice the sun makes it hot
we're on the chibi version now are you
prepared
thank you
[Music]
I think it's scary but Marcia's going
for it
oh okay she's doing good
I keep going backwards that's fine I
like it
[Music]
you're there we're switching up I really
miss going sliding I don't think I went
since I was like a kid oh in Sweden we
did on the right Club that's the [__]
it's as close as we get do you think
this is okay
I don't know if we're allowed
it's hard to tell in Japan ready
I like that it's fun
[Music]
hey guys
hey
why are you guys going to put that in
foreign
[Music]
can you tell it's snowing
ah you can't see on camera
that means you get to wish for something
we're uh charging the Tesla
that's the only one they have here we're
gonna go get some omiyage you cannot
travel in Japan without coming back with
gifts
gotta be careful here
[Music]
I think we're in the ginsadori
it's like a cute shopping area it's
really nice we just happened to stop by
oh that looks good
[Music]
they got canned bread
I gotta try it
[Music]
we're checking out can you guess it
another body of water oh God that's cold
it just blew on me
how's it going there
that's so pretty
[Music]
someone was cranky and I was asleep
hello
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
good morning look how much is that way
it's very cozy very cold minus seven
that's not that cold I'm just gonna go
have breakfast and
there's a big Outlet here that's famous
so we might check that out you guys
ready
trying Japan ends canned brain
bread in the can can I eat this in the
apocalypse until 24.
September it doesn't look bad imagine
there's the apocalypse and you find this
and it's October 24th
yeah it's good Cambria guy you wanna get
him right
do you want Cambridge
do you want camera
oh
can bread you get a two out of five
sorry Cameron
it's too messy I'm gonna eat today I
hate it I hate cameras
we're at this Outlet it's really cold
today I don't even want to take Momo out
because it's too cold for her even with
a jacket
they got nice shops here but I think
we're just here to check it out I don't
know if we're actually gonna buy
something
[Music]
everybody really gross because I feel
really gross
that was so spicy
it's the Korean one goddamn spicy
that's good though
[Music]
today we're going to a night man Marcy
has a surprise for me as a Valentine's
gift uh first we're going sushi
and then I don't know
so Friday finally
[Music]
the blossoming is coming close
some early ones
I've been here one time before during
Sakura and it's
it's beautiful but it's also packed with
tourists at this time so but I feel like
this year you know we earned it because
we've been here for this kind of marks
our first year almost now we get to ah
so next on the Valentine's itinerary
retro arcade there's one in odaiba that
is really good we've been there a long
time ago
retro rare kids are always so fun
[Music]
y'all remember this one
it looks strong marzian
you got it you got it
yes come on
one two three
yeah what is this
I've never seen a lot of these
[Music]
are the road
he's not he's doing a double change
laughs
[Music]
no
no oh
did I just lose
[Music]
that's not bad
foreign
[Music]
that was a hit
that's how we do
so these are all like different like a
weird Lottery you pick a lucky box
you shake them what do you think
this one looks like it's been here a
while you know
yeah I feel like that should be it
this is our lucky box
all right what do we get
what do we get
[Music]
come on thanks okay
all right
what okay yes eternals yes
thank you
[Music]
oh you're Chihuahua is that what's
happening
foreign